all right I think we are live welcome
everybody to the fake guru debate John
Kriss Donnie versus even I wore I wore I
wore a hat so you can't make fun of my
hair you hurt you hurt you hurt my
feelings in in in one of your last
videos yeah the other day actually I got
like a pretty bad haircut and somebody
was like hey you're making fun of John
crostini but you got to look in the
mirror bud so you know I understand that
the feels of that welcome everybody
thank you for joining us I'm your host
coffee Zilla I just wanted to give a big
shout out to John crostini for coming on
the channel I really appreciate him
having the guts to just say hey let's do
it man let's talk about it let's hash
out our differences and that's what
today is about it's not to yell or
anything like that and because of that
because it's not you know it's not gonna
be a slobberknocker we've got Spencer
van here to moderate the debate because
we're trying to keep it civil you don't
mean I'm back baby
I'm back I'm back so Spencer we have
some topics that we kind of thought
about beforehand that you know we might
disagree on we don't want to agree the
whole time one of motors disagree so
Spencer you want to kick it off there
yeah so we're gonna jump into really the
thick of things right away we're gonna
talk about refunds now obviously we've
got John crostini a course trader we've
got the man the myth the legend coffee
Zilla himself and because John is on
here on coffees on the show I think it's
fair that John gets to go first on the
first point so John refunds what do you
think about them and we'll get the
second sure
so my opinion on refunds is that if you
purchase a product if you make a
decision you have to stick by your
decision and that refunds are not part
that if you go to college you don't if
you're not happy with your four-year
university you don't go to the
university and say yeah I didn't I
didn't I didn't get a job you know I
didn't I didn't I I'm not being paid you
know I'm in $100,000 and dad you don't
go to your university and say hey can I
get a my $100,000 back I I feel like I
don't really know much more than when I
took John crostinis I took this guy job
for studies course I learned way more
you can't you don't go to the car
dealership and you say oh I want to you
know I want to refund on my car my
mortgage when we make decisions we have
to make decisions and we have to be
prepared for those decisions you know
and I think the whole problem with the
society these days is that we look at
everything the people are not principled
and this is why our focus is all over
the place this is why people are getting
divorced this is why families are not
happening or staying together it's
because people don't want to stick by
their decisions anymore and I think
people have to be prepared when they go
into something to stick by their
decision it's the only way to become
successful are you saying that divorce
is the real-life equivalent of a refund
yes it is yes I just compared divorce
and refunds exactly more anti-family
if you are anti if you are for refunds
so let me let me jump in here so I am on
the pretty far on the other end of the
spectrum but here's how I think about
the goal of a refund because I think
that's important to bear in mind here
what's the purpose of a refund well it's
the product does not work as advertised
am I am I thought about courses
especially given that there's such hard
sells usually and they promise so much
my thought is of course there should be
a refund if you're saying make $10,000 a
month you know with basically no work
with only a few hours of work put in if
you represent that to me on the front
end and say hey the secrets are all
locked in this little box over here and
you're only gonna get it if you purchase
I cannot make an informed decision about
your product without actually purchasing
it and seeing
what's inside the box and so it's not
fair to me to say once I've you know
opened it up and realized what I have
been promised is not actually in this
thing say oh well it was your free
choice
well my free choice was an uninformed
free choice and it was misrepresented by
predatory advertising so I mean I don't
I don't know if you have any thoughts
there but like I think you buy did you
buy one of these courses and think you
were just gonna make like ten thousand
dollars like day one or something hey
man that's what everyone tells me that's
what all the courses telling me they say
hey ten thousand dollars a month you
know four hours of work this isn't this
is legitimately the advertising given
and maybe you should say like we all
shouldn't be so credulous of advertising
we should all just assume everyone's
lying to us all the time but I'd prefer
to live in a world where the claims of
address I'm saying
what that's what I'm saying no no but my
point is is that I want to I think
people shouldn't be punished for taking
the advertising at face value if that
makes sense
does that mean yes and you I think you'd
agree the advertising on a lot of these
courses is very extreme I mean it is it
makes it sound like you're gonna be rich
like that so okay it makes it sound you
know and I you know that you go to you
go to a skincare store I don't know if
you've ever been to uh you know the mall
and you know they they sell skincare and
they say oh this is gonna make you look
beautiful you know very very subjective
term but I let's talk about these
educational courses so the educational
courses we're delivering online
education okay you nobody can you know
it's actually against the law to promise
results it's against the law to say you
will make ten thousand dollars if you
just pay me a thousand dollars it it's
not possible it's that's called a Ponzi
scheme if anything and it's it's against
the law so of course if people should
get refunds if they are not getting what
they were promised but these courses a
lot of them you know mine included we
are showing people how to make money in
that in
you're in your argument you're saying
that you know you should get a refund on
universities because universities say oh
you'll get paid more you know there's
some study 50 years ago that says you
will get a higher paycheck so the fact
that I went to university for four years
does that mean that you know and I
didn't get a job I didn't you know the
only job I got out of college was like
cold calling does that mean I should get
a refund on university because I didn't
get the intended results what are your
thoughts on that so here's what I think
all right when you go to university
their pitch their advertising pitch is
pretty clear I mean I'm not for like
for-profit colleges I'm gonna put to the
side we're talking about like mainstream
you know like a university education
what's the what's what's the pitch in
your State University like a State
University they say come here to get a
I'll take myself a chemical engineering
education right that's what they told me
I would get and I got a chemical
engineering education now how I separate
that from what gurus are saying is we'll
take you because you're on the call so
why not you John Chris Donnie are saying
and correct me if I'm wrong like part of
your thing is saying I'm gonna teach you
advertising but a main part of the pitch
is you're going to make money
you like whereas the college doesn't
necessarily do that they'll have like
average income claims which I think are
totally fair to put up but they won't
put like testimony like they won't say
like their main pitch won't be you're
going to be rich you're going to do all
this so you're saying kids are deciding
to go to school for four years to to
learn it's just because all of these
people are really interested in
educating themselves at 18 years old no
I would say that's what the
representation the university is making
of what you're going to get out of it
and they will put on the thing like
who's making who's getting jobs who's
not they're very transparent about how
their students are doing after they've
gone to college right like they're not
hiding the fact that there's some of
their students fail they'll say that
everything is like average what our
average student is making and I think
that's the fair way to show a business
opportunity but what gurus do and what a
lot of these internet courses are doing
is they're pitching the
they're saying like here hold on I put
up some copy from I'm jet set calm okay
so this is the start of I'm jet set calm
if you guys don't know that's John Chris
Danny's page right so let me pull it up
this is the if you pull it up on mobile
I believe this is what your show I'm
going to show this to the YouTube people
I don't know if you guys will see it
unless you have the livestream up okay
so this is discover my simple okay watch
this special limited time video discover
my simple three-step blueprint for
creating a twenty five hundred dollar
online income stream without any
experienced tech skills a product or
audience and then below that it says
start designing the life of your dreams
by earning ten thousand dollars extra
per month with just four hours of work a
week you can do this completely on the
side okay okay that that to me is is
ridiculous I don't think that's a fair
representation of what you're actually
offering you're offering an intro course
into affiliate marketing that is not
earning ten thousand dollars extra a
month with four hours of week on that
completely on the side like those two
things are completely different so so
that's my thought is college is
different in the way it represents its
income opportunity and by the way you
can get refunds from college when you
start them out they do have rain free
from policies just for the record you
can't so let me ask the chat here what
were the reasons what was what was the
main reason that you know if you paid
for college or if your parents paid for
college however it happened what was the
main reason you went to college okay
actually spent money for college was
were your parents pain so you could get
laid more you know have fun drinking
chat let me know what was the reason
yeah you went to college
okay and by the way I just want to shout
out this super chat
Cameron Glynn says love your content
coffee would like a refund on this
though when you can so guys if you super
chat we'll get to as many of those as we
can this is a fake guru scheme
me and John are splitting like so so
yeah guys answer John and if we purchase
I think college is a great point but I
would like to stick to refunds in
regards to okay you know what I just
think thank you Spencer I just wanted to
get the chats input the basement
everybody in the chat I basically see
the reason why everybody's being told
they go to college and is more money you
know of the at the end of the day the
pitch comes down to more money yet what
it really comes down to is people get
and you know people are going to college
and getting less they're getting more in
debt okay and what we're offering here
so in in my mind you should get a refund
on that and the reason why this is
linked is because what I'm offering is a
I'm offering people a real way to earn
money and look it's just Commission only
marketing it's teaching people to be be
sales salesmen of the internet it works
people are making ten thousand a month
people are making more than that I post
up testimonials you can look at Mike you
can look at my my channel comment feed
every single day I have people messaging
me about how much money they're making
so yeah some people are in 10,000 some
people are in a million a year
some people are nothing you know most
people earn nothing because most people
don't do anything so you have all ranges
in between just because but colleges
advertise these numbers too so my point
is and you come from a educated
background and you know I know you have
a you know a great deal of respect for
the for the education industry um you
know if you're if you're bashing gurus
you're bashing the education industry
you're not just but you're because
absolutely not hold on hold on let's
talk about that okay why would you say
that what you're saying else Steven yeah
I'm sorry go ahead go ahead
how can you be congruent with yourself
doing that because because colleges
aren't promising it's not a
get-rich-quick scheme whereas I would
argue the way
most people view horses it's a it's a
long-term get-rich-quick scheme it's a
earn 70 to 80 thousand dollars a year
put your money away in a Roth IRA
it's the nine-to-five that everyone
loves to hate on the nine-to-five that
actually works you know not coffee real
quick here cuz I think one of the points
that's that's really important here to
keep in mind John you mentioned earlier
you you you asked the chatting to
college yeah and I'm reading the chat
here that says basically one of two
things money or a job and I think John
one of John's main points here is that a
lot of people that go to college they
don't necessarily end up with a higher
paying job so should they get a refund
and isn't that kind of the same as the
person that goes in and I want to
reframe like this like refund thing it
goes back to what it was advertised
about John is arguing that the actual
connotation among society is that it
makes you more money because there have
been studies done that show that it does
like empirically it will on average make
you more money than if including debt
including debt including interest
including all that stuff the time
opportunity cost it will make you more
money but the actual objective
representation College makes to you is
not that Oh we're guaranteeing you a job
we're gonna we're gonna make sure that
you get $10,000 a month and so they're
advertising copy have you seen my order
form coffee your order form of like like
the earnings I'm not guaranteed money on
the order form when people check out at
the end of my funnel sure and at the and
on our sales page it says this is what
you will get we don't say pay me $50 and
I'm gonna give you $100 we never say
that we never say that you know that
course thing around it is marketing and
what I'm saying is colleges have created
this allure of marketing with studies
they themselves paid for conducted
saying that true is that sure are you
actually saying that they paid for
studies themselves to basically hype up
their own thing
no it's just it's that's just I I don't
have any references it's just okay I was
just that's fine that's what I want it
what I want to focus on though is
you are making the website right at the
top of the website
you were saying let me pull it up again
cuz it's great cuz I was like oh wow
this is exactly what I'm talking about
let me pull it up for chat again start
designing the life of your dreams by
earning $10,000 extra per month with
just four hours of work a week you can
do this completely on the side that is
like you're basically saying I mean
you're not saying it but even though I
believe the Federal Trade Commission has
something or has something about like an
implied income that you're gonna make
right like it's not just about saying oh
you hand me $5.00 I'll hand you $10 it's
also about implied that the implied what
they call a business opportunity right
you know about that where I'm considered
a business opportunity program not by
the word of the law but by Court
precedents yeah I do a lot of legal I
for I think I've more lawyers on
retainer than you I have four lawyers on
retainer to law firms to lawyers I know
the law I can't afford that rich life
man I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm just I'm
just a humble college goer here boys
indeed like I you know III know the law
here so trust me I know what I'm doing
yeah no no I believe you but what I'm
saying though is that's an implied
business income and and while there is a
disclaimer on your webpage even on the
that site that I was showing where it
says in tiny letters almost invisible
like even the text is not black it's
like gray against a white background you
know Pendragon Labs LLC makes no income
opportunity like representations blah
blah it's up to your hard work etc etc
etc are we goin with this I'm getting
bored the point is is that you are
implying that you are going to give
money and I'm differentiating that from
college where college does not guarantee
you're gonna make money therefore it
applies especially to gurus who say like
oh you need you're gonna make a ton of
money and they get in they're not
they're not making the money they should
get a refund because you're not giving
them what you're saying you're giving
them what you're implying you're giving
them so I mean we both a group we both
agree that
that you know that if somebody doesn't
get the product they want they should
get a refund I'm sorry you came on my
website and you like looked at the order
for him and he thought that you know
when you gave me $1,000 that you know I
was you know I was gonna like send you
attacks and be like yo bro what's your
venmo like let me send you 10,000 this
month but uh I mean did anybody I don't
know if there's anybody on here from my
side of the chat but did anybody on here
think that when they were purchasing or
going through any of my programs that
you that I was just kind of kind of like
text you and be like hey hey bro what's
your venmo what's your paypal uh can I
can I send you your ten thousand this
month no one thinks you're giving them a
VIN mo of ten thousand dollars thinking
that they're thinking that they're
thinking that I I think and we'll let
chat decide I think they're thinking
that when they see that that the income
opportunity is is we'll get that result
on average that's not an exceptional
income opportunity that's how it's
represented right so like because that's
what you're saying is that with this
simple blueprint you're gonna get this
much money I'm going to teach people how
to start a business which can make them
a large amount of money yes and that
what I'm delivering though let's let's
break it down what I if you go to my
order form you see I am delivering an
online education okay I'm delay there's
a lot of marketing around it just like
there's a lot of marketing around
selling college education which costs a
hundred times more but in either event I
am delivering what I'm saying and and
you know what how would I even be in
business why would I have why would I
why would I be in front of you today why
would I have four lawyers on retainer if
I wasn't delivering what I would I
actually say I'm and that's what
education is but if you're if you're
saying that just it you shouldn't you
know like you got a chemical engineering
education to go the idea was you'd make
more money you know so ever if you can't
speak against gurus without speaking
against the entire education system and
I think
just awful and what's crazy is that
there's so many people trying to make
trying to make a living right now and
you're keeping them stuck in this cycle
of debt by dissuade me okay okay okay
all right all right
now John let me jump in here okay this
is my channel no no don't don't ban me
or mute me no I won't but I have to jump
in here cuz you've said a lot of points
and I'd like to dress them before we go
on so one thing is is that you're saying
like I'm a successful businessman I have
four lawyers on retainer I'm obviously
doing this thing
therefore I'm legit I don't think that
logically follows I actually think that
there are a lot of you and I'm not even
saying you are at this very moment but
there are a lot of illegitimate
marketers who are making a lot of money
I think you would agree with that
statement wouldn't you there there are a
lot of it yeah yeah so so my point is a
lot of there's a lot of insurance
salesmen there's a lot of every success
has nothing to do anyone can have four
lawyers on retainer as long as they're
doing well financially that has nothing
to do with like the legitimacy of what
they're selling and then I would say
then I would say like if you're saying
I'm against college I'm definitely not
when I talk about gurus you'll notice
that most of the time I'm not talking
about the education within their propria
stablished that most people go to
college to make more money yet most
people large majority of people don't
get higher paying than average true this
is not true what you said what you said
after college no no I know but you're an
anecdotal example you're seeing the
majority now you're invoking statistics
and the statistics are against you on
this one
statistics show that if you go to
college you will make it's it's been
done like a million times every year a
new study comes out it's like as boring
as saying gravity is down and you know
whatever it's every year's new study
comes out yes
college is still worth it despite rising
income rising tuition despite the fact
that some people get chipped off by the
system and some people if you're going
into a sociology degree maybe it won't
make you a lot of money the majority of
people it is worth it for so
that's just not true which is what I'm
trying to say is that and also and also
what my bone to pick with gurus is
always they're advertising it's not like
hey John missed one part of affiliate
marketing
I believe you probably are an expert in
affiliate marketing but what I'm saying
is what you're saying the potential of
affiliate marketing is is not true for
the average average individual which is
where I have a problem because you're
selling it as any business period you
know any business period is not most
people don't become entrepreneurs period
most people don't even go into this
field of study that they purchased
college for most people end up in random
careers that are not associated with
their major right and that's that's true
but even still people with college
education even if they're in a field
unrelated to their degree they still on
average will make more money than
someone without a degree and over the
long voyage job then you're a slave
within your slave - oh yeah they're
saying having a job is being a slave I'm
100% that same having a job as being a
slave unless you have stock options if
you have stock options then you're smart
but if you don't have stock options
you're a [ __ ] slave this is actually
good hold on let's get into that let's
get to that in one second he's super
chats real quick
Cameron Glen says the reason is the
degree requirement is requirement for a
lot of jobs I didn't go to college to
get money I went to college to be
competitive that the course would be
valuable if it gave good info but
putting up your course on my resume
doesn't make me more competitive that's
a good point we haven't talked about
that side of it yet a big part of a job
is about that and then Mark F says what
percentage of John's students earn 10k a
month I want to return to this slave
question but can you do you know those
numbers what percentage of my students
earn money
no no 10k a month Oh ten came off no
idea we look at the we have we have we
have some overall numbers because I try
you know I have an earnings claim
disclaimer and all that stuff but uh I
don't know but I I know I come across a
number of people I I know I've had a
people who are millionaires now because
of my my trainings and I know a lot more
people I've heard quite a bit of money I
mean it's it's very basic its affiliate
marketing affiliate there's a lot of
people doing affiliate marketing it's
not it's not an unreasonable place to
make money and a lot of my students make
it so that being said it's like over 90%
of people fail but then again most 90%
of people are unfocused and they're
checking their Facebook every 30 minutes
and they don't really do a lot of work
okay there's your answer mark F let's go
on to if you don't mind we can focus on
this if you guys are interested in this
question but I wanted to touch on like I
think job is a slave is a really
interesting perspective I've never
thought of it that way before that's
fine I don't know who wins that round
but I don't I don't think you
effectively ever made an argument that
that if somebody's getting what they're
delivered that they should still get a
refund no no no I'm saying they're not
getting what they're delivered because
I'm saying that what gurus are promising
what you're promising is is an income
you're implying an income hey my order
if you're saying people should get a
refund on my course look look at the
order for the order form is very clear
what people are getting it I think I
think I think it's clear I think we've
got two points right
we've got point number one is and I
think this is where John is just trying
to make this point is that he's saying
that you have the opportunity to make X
amount of dollars right and I think
Steven I think Steven uh his rebuttal
that a Signori you're saying straight up
hey you're gonna make ten thousand and
John's rebuttal to that is well I never
said you know what you think you're
gonna buy my course I'm gonna demo you
right so that kind of brings us to it so
we are now right so it's it's kind of
it's kind of like I think you guys both
agree on
obviously hey if they're obviously not
getting what they you know what they
want and they should get a refund right
I think it goes back to the marketing
equation now right so so John let me ask
you this obviously as a course career as
a marketer yourself what would you say
is out of line like if you say this you
know specifically or things like this
that that should be considered hey this
is cool
not okay and you should get a refund and
then what is okay you know what is what
is allowed to be said in your own words
I think I mean one thing that we we do
is we let I mean we just let people know
up front you know there's no guarantee
of making any money that's how that's
how you know we're not we're not you're
not gonna pay us money and then we're
just gonna be like hey bro like what's
your venmo like let me send you some
money up and I don't think people think
that either and if they do it's I mean
that's crazy what I mean what I think
there should be is I I guess I think
there should be more transparency in the
industry like what's happening right now
I think I think coffee Zillow should
debate every guru I think I think if a
guru doesn't come on something like
coffee zillah's channel or isn't willing
to actually address the other side then
it means they have stuff too high I mean
if you're using if you're using two
first names if you're using a made-up
name I think I think teachers should it
thing to hide oh you guys are that but
the point being I think the culture of
having reviews and having blogs and
having people post about teachers I
think there should even be a central
repository which actually rates all the
different teachers out there because I
believe online education is here to stay
it's part of a coming wave people don't
want to drive to school people don't
want to go far away to college you get a
better education learning from guys who
are actually making millions of dollars
a year what what
then you do I always hoping I get some
of that money I'm gonna send you my vin
mow after this you you joked about it
but I'm gonna send you my Vinod but the
point is I people get a better education
and I think transparency is good but at
the end of the day transparent you know
it transparency use your real freaking
name you know his first thing but
there's a lot more that goes into that
so I I like overall
what you're doing but I highly disagree
because you are just telling people
don't buy online courses okay
and your dissuading people from actually
taking their life in their own hands
you're leaving them at the whim of going
to college and being going into debt and
getting you know basic yeah going into
debt which is further than broke and
becoming a slave to a job which is not
the way that you need to operate in
society I think you're tearing down one
side and there's some bad actors but
you're not offering any solutions and I
think that's a big a big fat problem and
a disservice to your entire audience all
right let me let me address that so
first of all you said I'm not offering
solutions I'm just saying hey go with
the status quo etc no I'm not what I say
is that oftentimes what you can find for
free online or for a very low amount of
money in a book is twice as good as what
you're gonna find in a gurus course so
what I say is not that just become an
autodidact learn to teach yourself what
is an autodidact anyway someone who's a
self learner somebody who is good at you
know and by the way I didn't learn that
in college I learned that in a book
because you know that's that's what you
have to do if you want to be an educated
person I agree with you college it
doesn't provide you all the answers
you've got to go like I'm doing YouTube
that's totally unrelated to engineering
I didn't want to do engineering so I did
something completely different College
gave me the help to me critically think
but I don't think that's the end-all
be-all and I wouldn't I'm not against
certain courses like if it's a udemy
course for 10 bucks I'm all about it and
they create great courses on there I'm
not about not investing in your
education but what I'm saying is these
high ticket courses are in my opinion
almost never worth it and almost are
never providing what they advertise in
implication now you might be able to
argue that objectively each one of these
people all have income disclaimers
everybody has an income disclaimer that
I'm not really promising this or this or
this but they kind of are and let me
give an example let me let me give you
an analogy to something that
not the guru business it's the medical
guru business where they say we're gonna
treat your memory problems right this is
common now and at the bottom of the page
they'll say this advice is not intended
to treat anything so that's a disclaimer
and before you order your thing you have
to agree that this this book or whatever
supplement you're buying isn't intended
to treat anything at all which totally
defeats the whole advert on ADD right
because the whole ad is telling you it
will treat everything I don't think
that's Eckel and I don't think that's
within the realm of like what we should
be allowing I see it very similar to
what's going on in gurus they say in
their advertising copy they make it seem
like the equivalent of solving all your
problems they say you could make this
much money a month you you're going to
its prayer it's easy I was just in your
shoes then I found my mentor and I'm
gonna be your mentor and you're gonna
make all this money at the very end they
basically give a disclaimer that defeats
the whole purpose of the entire ad which
is saying well we just don't know what
the hell is gonna happen
but I don't I don't think that's I don't
think that's right I think that kind of
advertising which is so prominent in
high ticket sales is not helping people
I want to address online education like
you said I actually agree with you
online education is here to stay I think
it's a good thing I just don't think the
high ticket stuff with the kind of
advertising that's going on is helping
anyone so I don't think it's productive
so yes I criticize it but it's because
when there's so much high ticket stuff
out there and there's so many extreme
claims how can good educators make their
mark how can good educators make their
mark when they all they can promise is
well I'm gonna teach you a basic skill
which is a good thing but when you're
going up against somebody who's gonna
say I'm gonna make you $100,000 you know
in your first 60 days or whatever you're
not saying that but there are gurus who
do I think actually I need to brush up
on that but there's a lot of crazy
income like claims out there you will
not be named yeah yeah yeah there's a
lot of crazy income claims out there and
the point is is that when an honest
educator goes up against that guy he
loses ten out of ten times and so I'm
against the advertising so first off I'm
happy you agree with most my major
points I mean
that's pretty cool and thank you you
know I'm happy we both you know I think
it's also cool that we agree that online
education is is uh is here to stay as
your I personally you know so so III
don't know what worked
I don't know what so what exactly are we
talking about now like is it worth it
you know why do I charge a thousand
dollars for a course rather than udemy
charging ten dollars or what what are we
talking what what do you want to talk
about because you Spencer designed the
next question I'm gonna hit these super
chats real quick the checkmark on his
order form obviously makes everything
okay Kristen Kristen E is no professor
god this is mean I dropped out of
college he tries to spin his BS is
education sorry let's keep it light guys
you know if you believe in your course
so much exact the chat they're not like
but take a percentage instead of a
one-time fee even 1% would earn you more
return over the course of a year at 10k
a month
okay this Cameron Glen this guy's saying
basically have you ever thought of
taking an income based on what that
person's projected earnings which if
you're if these people are making
millions of dollars would still net you
a great income that's interesting point
and then do you want you want to address
that real quick before I hit this next
one or should I just go through them
that's that's a the whole that's a
common that's a common thing you hear as
kind of like a I guess a guru or a
teacher what's interesting is they're
actually they're actually some new
schools that are coming out there's like
a whole like venture capital fund which
is testing out the model of you know
pain for people's education 100% and
then making the money back by garnishing
their income
the problem with garnishing somebody's
income is that I don't know how you can
legally do that I I don't think there's
a legal way where I can say okay you
know anybody who has gone through my
course who does anything related to
marketing or who gets stuff related from
Mike
I'm gonna garnish their income or the
part of their income for the next ten
years based off of what they learned
from me nor do I think that's fair
necessarily I think you pay for
education you don't get your income
garnished there I just don't know of a
way with the government of where you can
actually create a legal agreement I mean
that's like that's it's an interesting
question but I don't I don't actually
know of any like software tool or legal
agreement where I could legally anybody
who purchases my course I'm garnishing
their income for the next ten years
because that that you know I have tens
of thousands of students so that that
would be that would be kind of cool but
I just don't know of a way okay
Zack Adam and I you don't you know and
anybody who wants to say oh just trust
me bro I'll I'll PayPal you PMS I'm not
gonna my money you know that we all know
that would never actually work so all
right Zack Adam says as I recall on his
previous videos coffee Zilla has
actually advocated for trade technical
schools as a cost-effective alternative
to college that's true
Thank You Zack new hack every week
yo coffee Zilla have me on soon sometime
soon mate I'm a clickfunnels tu cama
legit not from selling courses but
recently gave in and made a course I'm
also a university lecturer that never
went myself and think it's a big-time
scam I would love to have yan why don't
you hit me up in my business email matin
says things coffees illa for whatever
I'm gonna not gonna read the ones that
are rude to you know you guys I want to
address one point real quick I'm gonna
link to this in my people are like why
am I not in like a super super fancy ass
super fancy ass house and whatnot first
off I don't believe in spending needless
money second off I my house burned down
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
my house burned down I have two acres in
Malibu and my house burned down last
year and the fires were in the process
of rebuilding so
Yeah right snaps in chat boys that
honestly sucks I'm sorry oh yeah I'm in
a rental it's uh you know it's it's it's
like four bedroom house you know I have
two kids but yeah it's not it doesn't
have glass it doesn't have like floor to
wall floor to ceiling glass windows and
like a view of the house ivy you can see
my old property in if you look at the
video I posted in the chat or if you go
to my channel we have a pretty sick
property we have a horse ranch so we
have like a horse arena and we all did
blah blah blah but but uh yeah my house
burned down so that's what I'm not in
anything fancy plus you tend to justify
the fact they make a ton of money with
like a nice house but but but the other
thing is like that's that's all [ __ ]
is the fact that you have to actually
look that that you you know people say
this to me oh why why don't you you know
like wear a suit more often and all this
stuff that's such a [ __ ] image of
people being rich boss in the Bentley
you know what it's [ __ ] most
millionaires actually drive trucks if
you look at it you'll warren buffett
drives the same like toyota tacoma he's
been driving for the last thirty years
you it's not about looking fancy I mean
this is a john for vados you know the
sweater but it doesn't look fancy I'm
not I'm not out there to try to be super
flashing
the point of money is not to be flashy
or fancy it's to do it's just yourself
I've Lamborghinis in my ads because
that's what people want to see but who
but but it's it's it's that's marketing
right I'm a marketer but again normal
normal people you don't have to don't
buy into that and also if you're looking
for people that are always fair I mean
it's I just think it's all [ __ ]
sorry I just want to address that no no
I think it's valuable I want to hit this
up too because we got a nice super chat
for you here lastly I appreciate you
coming on the show John I like the
baiting and I do respect the fact you
came on that's from Cameron Glen and I
want to emphasize that guys this is not
supposed to be like a
big rose fest because ultimately the
goal here is to get more people talking
more gurus on the show
John just has the balls to come on even
though he knows it's gonna be kind of a
tough crowd so my no seriously I tip my
hat to you for reaching out you reached
out and I appreciate it because you know
it's it's kind of a little rough out
there you know in the chat I've checked
the chat every once in a while I see and
I'm back to the to the debate I do
actually have a quick question and then
it will wrap up kind of a refund point
of this because I think we've hit that
enough this one's for Stephen actually
so we talked about earlier
you showed John's kind of his landing
page and this headline in a sub-headline
and all that and you know obviously we
don't have exact numbers and all of that
but hypothetically here if we just make
a number let's say one of the ten people
that sign up for John's or anyone's
programs get results and that one at a
ten person makes the 10k that is in the
headline does that justify it does that
mean that he's allowed to say that even
if the other nine necessarily don't have
that level of success but I have some
level of success whether they make money
or hey you know what maybe they buy this
course they learn a foundational level
of business and then they end up doing
something else just like you would in
college right with your chemical
engineering degree how you didn't
necessarily go down that path you know
what what are your thoughts on that I
think that's totally fine and and I
think the big point here though what I
want to stress and what I want the Guru
industry to do more of is get more
objective met nice and nice John get
more objective metrics on what their
students are actually doing right like I
think that's so important to actually
know how much and sometimes it's hard to
get this data I understand but if you
can prove that I think that's huge and I
think that should be all over your ad
like one out of ten of my students are
making make of this money like clearly
it's a formula that works but what I
don't accept and what all the Guru's do
is they just use anecdote anecdote
anecdote anecdote a lot of my guys are
achieving success and it's like they
never bring up the people they ban from
their Facebook group I'm not saying you
do this John but a lot of people do
banned from their Facebook group for
complaining about the fact they're now
in debt because of their
course right they never talk about those
guys so I don't accept the anecdotal
argument I want to see more statistics
but I'd be happy if people included more
of that I want to see more of it John
real quick you got anything to add of
that before we move on okay so that's
the refund section so the next part of
this debate is maybe talk about
financing and what we mean by financing
is is it okay to go out and take on debt
to educate yourself via online courses
now last time we had John starts I think
it's fair that we have Stephen start
this debate so Stephen financing for or
against and why very against financing
because I think the kinds of people it
attracts are it just perpetuates a
predatory business model because
unfortunately the people who are very
commonly found as victims of these of
these well I would call them scams some
people call them other things these high
ticket guru courses that people feel
like they're gonna make a ton of money
they're often people that are not making
a lot of money they're desperate and
because they're desperate they're
willing to do anything and financing
allows them to go in the hole which is
always a bad idea but especially a bad
idea for a high risk investment John
himself said 90% of people fail meaning
90% of people and I agree and I think
that's a fair admission but if you say
90% you have a 90% chance of this
investment not working out for you don't
go into debt for that investment no one
would tell you that right like that's a
very bad idea it's like buying a lottery
ticket like what you're not gonna
suggest people go buy lottery tickets
especially on credit so why are we doing
that for for guru courses if if the
failure rate is really bad which I think
everybody agrees it kind of is so no I'm
a very much not in favor I'll say real
quick it's not illegal to offer
financing but I think a predatory and
illegal are two different things and
it's gonna be my contention I'm gonna
let John respond but it's my contention
that fake guru courses are preying on
broke desperate young people
John so first off yeah you know
financing going into debt for things um
let's talk about thing you know people
go into debt for their house people go
into debt for a car people go into debt
for an education people go into debt for
a variety of reasons
you know they buy you know they even
finance sofas now if you want to get you
know like some fancy sofa people go to
debt for all sorts of dumb material
things that are never going to take them
hot you know anywhere in life a nicer
car is not going to help you be a better
person or earn more money whereas
education and an educational course and
learning from legitimate teachers is the
best thing you could ever go into debt
for period so I'm all for it
okay yeah I'd like to like respond to
that real quick so first of all there is
a specific type of financing that I'm
very against which is unsecured loans
are which are typically much higher
interest rates and what I've seen is
that it's it gets people to spiral keep
trying to and keep trying to make their
money back right and so I've had several
of these people on my program where they
go oh I bought dan Locke's course and
then I bought his uplevel because well I
didn't make any money and then I bought
my his up level and then I didn't make
any money and then I tried to buy his
dan Locke millionaire mastermind
whatever it is and my credit card got
declined cuz I'm so far in the hole but
the point is they just chased it forever
they just chased it forever of like oh
I'm good I'm just it's just the next
it's won by my success is won by around
the corner right and so why I feel that
about specifically courses is I feel
like there are two kinds of things that
I know of that are very demand inelastic
and so what I mean by that is that there
is no price at which you would not pay
for these two items those two items are
things
that will make you wealthy and things
that will make you healthy so if you are
have cancer anybody can pay you any
price they'll tell you to any price for
any drug and you're gonna pay it right
yeah yeah there's a certain price at
which American society kind of we kind
of get discussed it we're like this is
gross and people are getting in you know
they're getting sick they can't pay for
this drug okay let's call this what it
is
it's predatory we need like drug price
controls even though from a capitalist
perspective they can charge whatever
they want so I feel the same way about
courses so courses are the same if you
promise me that I'm gonna make thousands
of hundreds of thousands of dollars
maybe you have an income disclaimer that
says I shouldn't believe any of that but
I but if I believe you
I will pay any price for it and so I
think it is a quick rabbit hole down
into further debt and getting into a
worse place than you start it yeah yeah
I you know what I'm like yes obviously
medical you know like medical you can go
into debt for but uh no I I just you
know what this is the same discussion as
kind of like is it worth it like how far
are you willing to go if something's not
worth it
don't buy it if something's you know
great I say go you know go into debt you
know go to debt for it you're trying
you're improving your mind you're
helping you're helping yourself overall
that being said we don't actually yet we
actually we do seminars and we have you
know I do I actually have a seminar
coming up next week we have a couple
hundred people if anybody here on the
channels going to my seminar see you
guys there Vegas baby
put relaxing chat if you're going to
Vegas I don't think anybody here's but
uh but the point yeah if you're going to
Vegas let me know for Affiliate Summit
I'll see you guys out there but uh dude
we have a crazy party we have I set up
some good parties but overall we
actually don't do financing in my in my
company because it there there are live
there are additional legal liabilities
with financing that we just don't we
just don't
mess around with that being said I am
all for it okay let me let me get to a
view these chats real quick sorry sorry
to interrupt real quick I'm gonna blow
up blow through them and I want to hit
this one specifically because it's not
for John it says course has got me out
of my job I'll be debt-free in a couple
months and only worked from a laptop
from anywhere not possible with my old
banking job nice let's see here Tim
Parkin says John's course teaches you to
sell his course true or false he
mentioned Ponzi schemes if true doesn't
that make him a Ponzi scheme please
discuss let me get through these real
quick Johnny doe says John do you have a
course on beards nice yeah you should
it's pretty nice beard you know I'm not
gay bro but nice ba bro got a wife yeah
yeah thank you guys again thanks for all
these chats and then finally we have
life insurance dojo coffee Zilla most
coarse sellers will refund if people are
upset in order to protect their hai
dispute rate because if you get too high
of a dispute you're striper Pay Pal will
ban your business no scammer can keep
the account okay nice thanks for that do
you want to address
Tim Parkins thing while Spencer is gone
real quick about John's course teaches
you to sell his course true or false he
mentioned Ponzi schemes if that's true
mate doesn't make it a Ponzi scheme
don't address that yeah so a Ponzi
scheme is where he put money in and you
are supposed to get money out a multi
now the next thing what he actually is
trying to refer to is that it's a
multi-level marketing program meaning
that it's it's that I'm teaching people
how to which it's not it's it's it's so
yes I am teaching people how to sell my
course within my course I'm teaching
them how to sell my program and that's
part of the reason why I do teach it
well I basically I use it as my example
throughout my course so I needed one of
the issues that I came up against
because affiliate marketing programs are
always going up and down basically I
said I need an example to use for
teaching people Google Ads Facebook Ads
you know YouTube ads
cetera so I just always use my course
and I offer my students a lot of
materials in which they can use to sell
my course the other so it's just it's
like a one-level because there is no
because multi-level marketing is like
you sell a guy on selling a guy on so
there's what it's it's all one level
it's all one level and the other thing
is about it is that technically they're
not even technically there's not even
one level because they're actually
working with Clickbank so like there's
even so that's how technically there's
it's this weird thing but it's not
multi-level it's not a Ponzi scheme
it's literally I just use show them how
to sell my own products and that also is
an additional reason why I'm teaching
and why I've been teaching so long is
because when my students have success I
see it you know I see it I see them
selling my programs if they're marketing
my programs so some most of my students
go market other stuff they market like
weight loss offers or whatever the hot
skincare or like muscle supplement
offers are out there
I do see a number of my students will
remain after my six week program
marketing my course and that that gives
me it means when they make money I make
money so I'm either way because there
may I make fifty percent of what they
make so it is I am kind of making money
from my students success if you so to
speak and and again you know to back up
even further you know people are like
why do you know just learn for ten
dollars on udemy I I wouldn't be you
nobody would ever learn for me I would
put up any educational content I
wouldn't have a youtube channel I
wouldn't be teaching people if I was
selling $10 courses on udemy it just
doesn't make sense for me money-wise so
I just wouldn't be teaching there
wouldn't be any content from me the
reason why I'm teaching is you know I I
charge high and well yeah I think
there's not enough money in it if you
sell oh no if I was selling on udemy and
udemy takes fifty percent of that five
dollars
just it's it's a horrible Platte you
can't be you there's no business model
for teachers really on udemy there's a
couple people who have sold a couple
hundred thousand courses but it's it's
uh I I won't be teaching it if I have if
I relied on something like udemy I
charge high because I I believe I offer
a lot of value though some people in the
chat just wanted to see me keep putting
my hat on yeah all right let's go back
to the debate real quick
you said financing I do have a question
actually really like for you about
financing they're in this cuz
specifically Stephen somebody mentioned
the chat a little bit ago they said when
does it become the person's decision you
know like we're talking about financing
we're talking about refund guarantees as
if it's like these people are being
completely and utterly controlled by the
person being sold to so what does it
become the the buyer the the person
buying the course what does it become
their responsibility and when does it
become like hey you're making the
decision to go into debt for this thing
and you know like what is it on them
versus what is it on the the course
creator or owner so that's a really good
question obviously there's not a group
there's not a simple black and white
answer I don't think anyone can offer
you a simple black and white of what is
advertisings responsibility to be honest
and truthful and what is the individuals
responsibility of due diligence there is
no way to like fully hash that out where
where what I would say is that because
wealth courses have a special place in
people's mind and what it pushes them
over the edge of that buying decision in
a way that other products do not it's
just up for a higher level of scrutiny I
can't exactly say like yeah when when it
makes sense and it's like someone's fair
play to go into debt for some course I
mean I I can't answer that question I
just would have to say the more honest
the advertising is the more it's on the
person's decision so if John said like
his advertising copy is hey what
all I'm doing here is teaching you guys
affiliate marketing then I would say
like offer financing and if people want
to buy it they buy it because that's
like really what he's doing it every
single person would get exactly what was
represented in his advertising so I'd be
fine with that the farther away you get
from your course content versus the
dream that you're kind of the emotional
buy you're pulling on the more I think
it's like on John crostini to be you
know to be wary about what he's
delivering etc yeah I I feel like we've
already gone over this it's basically
like is it you know let's move on I want
to talk about our next topic I'm excited
man let's get this let's get this thing
going cuz oh man this next time are your
audience lost my like hair they keep
saying like to put my hat on or so do I
don't understand this the hats not
staying on we're gonna get racks oh look
at this look at this you're gonna get
that hair no knots okay that's what
you're stuck with people alright so our
next topic is we're gonna go through a
host of gurus and we're gonna get your
guys's thoughts on them with you guys
think they're legit they're not legit
they're good they're bad I'm not gonna
live them I've been excited I've been
waiting for this part I gotta say this
John turn your phone off don't let any
notifications go tell us the truth yes
which is why you were yes I've liked
interact you know I do business with
some of these people you're the best
person to tell it straight we're talking
about transparency baby let's let's get
some transparency there's there's a lot
of people on this Chad okay and I think
I think we should start with a person
that's been in the news a lot lately
at least the coffee Zilla news and I
think we should start since I think
everyone on the stream probably knows
coffees opinion on this person I think
we can start with John John what is your
opinion on Stefan James Stefan James
actually so here in jury
I have interesting stories about the guy
great guy legit thumbs up great marketer
tenacious person
amazing amazing mindset surprisingly
humble I actually met him before I was
even like successful in affiliate
marketing when back in I had met him
first
in I believe 2012 or I was even before I
had quit my job or anything uh at a at a
Tony Robbins event and he's he was a
nice guy I don't know I think we were
sitting or we met somewhere in the in
the event and he's he's a really
legitimately cool person and we've we've
hung out we've hung out a few times here
in Venice and he's really interested in
learning in life and he cares about
people so I give him a I give him a two
thumbs up I mean I have nothing bad to
say about it right
Stevan anything you'd like to claim this
I'm gonna disclaimer I don't know Stefan
James is a person right we've never had
any back and forth I've offered to speak
with him about you know the things I've
said whether he thinks they're true or
not true whatever and he has not
responded to me personally so all I can
go is off his actions and specifically
from 2012 to 2015 roughly he was
engaging in some really shady blackhat
Kindle publishing books promoting
medical cures to incurable diseases on
those grounds on I would just call
anyone who promotes incurable disease
cures a scumbag I can't say anything
about the legality or anything but I'll
stay I don't appreciate that I don't
think and I think he purposely made it
disconnected it from his personality
because I think he wanted to both enjoy
the fruits of a blackhat game without
having to suffer the reputational damage
of what he was actually doing and still
he has not copped to what he actually
did which I find unbelievable it's like
dude just admit it
say you're sorry say you've moved on and
let's be all done with it so
they have a I'll respond to that with
they have a scene in Russia nobody
talked about how they make their first
million dollars yeah I I just I hate
that I mean that's such market like oh
yeah like if you're not cheating you
ain't trying kind of idea like oh just
everyone's gonna do it no it's not true
people make legit millions it's a good
saying though I mean it's a good thing
but uh yeah I don't know I don't agree
that at all okay moving on to the next
guy on our list here
Alex Becker what do we think about Alex
Becker Steven I'll let you I'll let you
go first okay so I haven't actually like
in ER it's shocking cuz he's a big guru
and never roasted him on this channel no
I've never roasted him on this channel
which is insane because he definitely
deserves it to some extent look I I try
to stick with as much as I can the facts
of what I know about gurus unfortunately
becquer just like Tai Lopez has kind of
just avoided my research watchlist for a
while he'll eventually you know get his
his fair shake but I'd rather hear what
John has to say because I feel like John
you know him well
yeah we want to hear your opinion first
I mean probably a fake guru like I would
say 70% chance of being a fake guru it's
like it's like I'm like a meteorologist
right now all I can give you guys as
percentages big chance of rain right now
raining fake gurus okay I'll keep it
real on this one I know Spencer I know I
know your thoughts on this subject so
first off I see Alex Becker anybody here
else no I guess people know what I
expect I'll know who Alex Mack yes okay
really really highly intelligent guy
great work ethic in regards to his
knowledge and his ability as a marketer
top of the top a few things though one
is he's not an e-commerce to my
knowledge he's not an e-commerce person
himself he's a great
marketer but he's he doesn't actually
teach his own courses so I don't view
him as a I guess you know for what he's
selling which is you know he's he's a
pitchman he's a pitchman and he's a
pitchman for I think ecommerce currently
now my view on things is I always teach
my own courses if I'm teaching affiliate
marketing people need to hear it from
the from the mouth of the horse so to
speak yeah okay there's no substitute
for if there's no subsidy if you're
buying a course from a guy who says he's
a multi-millionaire and you want to
learn from you know he's made millions
in affiliate marketing
you want to hear from that person you
don't want to hear from his his trainers
I totally agree with this yeah so
another thing about Alex Becker I think
recently he's a little like I am I
really watch his stuff and he's one of
the few gurus I really followed because
he is so intelligent I'm interested to
see where he goes I think he's very
unfocused actually overall I think he
works hard but overall I have yet to see
how focused he is because he was selling
education but now he's trying to build a
software program pretty different so I
I'm I'm interested I feel like there's
something inside of him that doesn't
fully believe in online education as a
business model or as maybe what he's
teaching he doesn't fully believe in so
there's so there's something off there
but uh you know so that's that's the
only thing but that being said I mean
I'm I'm a member of his mastermind I
followed the guy he's one of the
smartest marketers around he's a highly
intelligent person and I really like the
videos he's been coming out with lately
on his a youtube channel because there
instead of just trying to sell his
course or whatever he's just kind of
like dropping knowledge bombs all all
over the place so that's why well III
didn't want to do this but just because
I know becquer I saw you chomping at the
bit
yes that's right I'm gonna add something
in from my guy the moderator queue my
knowledge and this is actually gonna be
probably news to you Steven he actually
doesn't sell courses to beginners
anymore he only does
business-to-business stuff now to my
knowledge now I could be wrong but he
said that I respect that and I'll go on
the record and saying if that's true I
respect it I just thought I just thought
that would be important I didn't okay
we'll have to figure that out later
super chat real quick let me grab the
super Trevor I don't know I fight a
machine yeah I can't confirm but that's
what I'm doing all right
TJ Blackmore says is it ethical to
target people under 18 with
get-rich-quick schemes children's brains
are underdeveloped and the lack life
experience - who discerned scams from
reasonable claims why target them John
you know what I I think kids need to
learn how to make money online more than
anybody else
I mean affiliate marketing is the only
thing that can be done under the age of
18 on the internet so III have I see I
think every children should be learning
how to make money online and if you are
teaching your kids to go to a job I
think you're crazy teach them how to
make money on the computers there they
can be a billionaire by the time they
turn 19 like these kids are making more
money than me some kids just sold his
company for like 5 billion yesterday and
he's like 20 years old get your kids
started early and make em but but teach
him that computers are for making money
not social media because social media
messes up their brain if they know that
computers are for money I think that's
great teach and put them to work I don't
get what the big problem with this is we
make kids do chores make kids go to
school and do homework get them to buy a
thousand dollar course right that'll
work on the internet no have their
parents buy the course I don't think I
don't think 12 year olds can buy courses
but the parents should buy for them 100%
okay Wow I don't want to respond I don't
want to respond to this because I don't
want to open a can of worms I wanted a
chat you asked it was no no no I
appreciate it say I appreciate the
answer I wanted to we need to grab these
chats you know but let's let's go on
here sorry
oh poor kids you know there go through
it online go ahead go ahead
the Nazca room we'll go back to John you
can start on this one is say mothers do
you have an opinion on Sam Evans he's
kind of weird I I don't know I haven't
gone through his courses I haven't gone
through his stuff he's kind of weird
like I see people saying like I'm like a
psychopath in the comments like I'm not
gonna go I'm not gonna go ahead John go
ahead let him have it but I mean it's
slow here did he just he doesn't blink
okay here's what I'll say he doesn't
blink weird but that being said I think
he's fantastic his courses are I've
heard from so many people that have gone
through his up level consulting course
that it's been very very very helpful I
don't know I've actually heard a lot of
good just feedback now his course is
more so for professionals it's not
teaching people who are like you know
they have like $2,000 to their name
trying to figure out how to sell [ __ ]
his course is literally it's for
accountants it's for like notary publics
it's for lawyers it's for book it's it's
for like people with professions like
therapists like people with some sort of
like expertise or specialty
seem to be very well served by his
course and are able to sell their
services for much more and I've
personally come across people who have
done that and used his call
basically they're just combining their
expertise with like internet marketing
and charging much higher rates I think
it's actually really some and I haven't
been through the course but so I think
he's a good teacher
I think he's dedicated to the students I
think his courses are great from what
I've heard but he's kind of a weird up
he's kind of a weird guy oh I like that
I like the honesty man yeah
I I wouldn't be a person I'd go to a
party with let's put it that way
fair I think that is a fair criticism of
Sam Savin do you have I'm actually gonna
not be Steven right now I'm gonna be
Dave Rogan moser and I want you guys to
know that Sam ovens saved my life he got
me together with my wife he got me a job
he made me millions of dollars and I'm
not reading off a script right now guys
I'm a hundred percent an honest
testimonial you know I he he fixed
everything I used to be a bum on the
street and I took one course with Sam
Evans and now I'm a multi-millionaire I
have nothing but amazing places a guy my
name is Dave Rogan moser
and you can find me in other reviews
that are may may or may not be paid so
so that's my review of Sam Evans
okay moving on to the next I mean this
is like the Guru grandfather right here
I mean I know our you know you're gonna
say the same the man the myth the legend
Tai Lopez shoot and we'll start with
even on this night Tyler tais really
interesting because he made me start
thinking about what Google's role and
Facebook's role in regulating gurus is
because as you guys know the gurus spend
a lot of money on Facebook and Google
and I don't obviously I think ty Lopez
is a faker let me get that off right off
the bat duh like you said grant
grandpoppy of fake gurus right but what
I'll say about him is that
Google and Facebook have regulations
about get-rich-quick get-rich-quick
schemes and I was watching a podcast of
ty Lopez and he talks about like the
concierge service that he gets for
spending so much money on Google Ads
like he was talking about how oh they to
Google ad guys flew out a chopper to go
see me because I spend so much money on
Google advertisers I'm like one of their
number one advertisers besides like
coca-cola
it's like coca-cola and then ty Lopez
for ad spend at a certain time like
during his heyday of like you know I
hear in my garage but because of that I
thought to myself like oh Google has a
vested interest in not cracking down on
this guy and I had never realized that
before so as far as ty Lopez fake guru
he's kind of annoying he reminds me of
like dan Bilzerian a little bit like he
tries to evoke a similar vibe of getting
the girls getting the cars getting the
whole like fake lifestyle whatever but
you know I I did appreciate the fact he
shifted my thoughts to think like what
is googles and Facebooks role in all of
this in like protecting consumers
obviously I don't think they should be
blameless their algorithms were the one
finding people and pushing audiences
right John do you have a response to
that yeah I bet you could guess it guys
a genius guy so smart I mean the fact
that he was you know I I've done a bit
of research in him I've done video on my
channel the fact that the guy was
basically like you know not making much
at the time and took a camera of foam
video and turned it into like a
gazillion dollars [ __ ] hats off to
him okay so my argument so here that
said I'll have a few things and I've met
ty Lopez I think twice just briefly um
first off I think the gay I think the
guy gives what he promises he's telling
people he's going to give him book
summaries for $67 a month he gives him
book summaries he tells it
students that they can pay him mm you
know when he start you know he's like
hey you can get a video of me and my
commentary on the books book you know
the book summaries for $2,000 you know
he delivered reviews of books so he's
never been like that he had a social
media thing which he was teaching people
how to sell create their own social
media marketing agencies but he never
really created a social media marketing
agency so I don't maybe he has since
then I don't know what some of the
problems I have with him are that one I
don't really view I don't think he's he
isn't really teaching most of his
courses most of his course he's more
he's more of a pitchman okay he's a
pitchman he's pitch in real estate
course crypto course credit repair
course affiliate marketing course
ecommerce course he's really just turned
into a big pitchman and he did I think
he has some interesting things to say on
mindset I think he does know a little
bit about mindset and what it takes and
the tenacity it takes to become
successful in business but I don't know
how six I don't think he was that
successful before he actually became a
teacher honestly he I know he made money
though he did he made at least hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year from my
understanding of it because he started
these like shitty dating websites and he
was it you know he basically he started
I don't have you done the research on
him I knew about the Wesley I watched
your video about him I thought it was
pretty okay yeah but he actually made
money before being a teacher so I think
there is some legitimacy but I'd say the
lion's share was made afterwards and the
fact that he doesn't teach most of his
own courses I don't he's not high up
there I think he's I think he's legit in
terms of mind said I don't think he's a
faker I wouldn't call him a scam but I I
wouldn't say he's full
like let's let's let's teach people fair
enough now or out of 10
four out of Sam Evans weird hotties
rating too weird out of ten sama-sama
Sam Evans is like you know he's up there
like a toy he's actually a smart guy but
besides besides like what would I know
about him he seems to be one of the like
pretty intelligent givers yeah he's
pretty he's pretty smart
now this next guy I don't can I say his
name I don't want to get you in trouble
Oh Steven Ayane the general I don't know
no genuinely I think it's fine I think I
think well maybe it's okay if I said it
right but if you can't okay if you say I
just won't say it right I mean I could I
could say it backwards that'd still be
the kind of first names on both sides
you get sued well I don't want to get
sued so uh we'll just call them look the
Kevin David from Twitter okay that got
it so I'm talking about okay what do we
think about the Kevin David from Twitter
like a small ego
one of the craziest things I've realized
by the way risk again respect to John
come in on like a man and just face in
the music like I don't understand it if
I were if I were a guru I was making
millions of dollars I'd be like you can
say whatever you want about me I don't
care I'm taking this to the bank baby
but the fact that a lot of gurus for a
lot of gurus like they're so fragile and
the second you say anything bad about
them they want to delete you they want
to sue you they want to do anything to
remove your comments about them it just
seems to be really petty so I look I
haven't taken the guys course I'll say
he has taken a lot of other people's
content he's stolen a lot of other
Creators content not just like their
ideas but literally in some cases word
for word what they've said he copyright
strike that video
but also like he's just uh small dude
I'll just leave it at that just uh
that's what I think of when I think of
Kevin David like that John I put it up
post basically I put up a post in the
comment in the chat if you guys want to
hang out with me and Kevin at my party
there's you're not gonna get in just
just real quick word you can hang out
Kevin David's kind of you know like we
hang out from time to time like we know
each other like I think the guy's a
douchebag okay so like Kevin love you
your cool guy we're chill Oh
douchebag bro you're total douchebag and
you're you're you're Tweety Bird haircut
um you know what I I think you know if I
get enough comments about my hair you
know um no so Kevin and me actually met
because I I think what is it he
challenged me to a rap battle or so I
forget what happened but we had a rap
battle at one point it was awful I hired
people on Fiverr to write verses again I
don't know he's a funny guy so he's a
douchebag I think I think Kevin is I
thought you scared him off
I thought you scared him off I thought
you scared him off of youtube I know he
came back recently I've got to make a
video about it I just haven't gotten
around to it the bro I I will say Kevin
you gotta thicken your skin bro
you know like like like like haters are
part of the game you know this but I
yeah I thought you were most scared him
off of YouTube so I was uh we can all I
was iced that being said I haven't been
through his courses so I don't do
e-commerce so I have you know I don't I
don't have anything to comment there I
know he I know he built a software which
is pretty cool he like took all these
softwares and you know I I promoted as
software a week ago I think it's pretty
rad but uh yeah I mean I you know I
don't know I think whatever you hear
that
but that's I think that's Kevin's
lawyers at my door they're coming for
you next John you're gonna get it
they're coming for you yeah yeah yeah
by the way John coming with the smoke
just coming out guns a-blazing I like it
I like it I was worried you were gonna
do like the like oh he's just such a
great guy everybody well you know we're
cool we're both I don't know we're like
we're you know we're we're we're bro you
know we're partying together you know
we're gonna be hanging out in Vegas
we're gonna be hitting the clubs
together we're gonna be doing fun [ __ ]
together but I you know like I don't
know the way about you know my friends
are cool if I call them out a little bit
but you know I yeah I don't have
anything like crazy bad to say about
Kevin yeah cool are we gonna ever
address the Bentley I don't don't don't
worry about Chad is going crazy you let
me moderate okay I'm only kidding ah
next guru though and it's funny because
I've seen some pop up in the comments
that would be a true that too we can add
those at the end if you guys would like
to keep continue on with this but that's
guru is a tanner fox when you guys think
of tanner fox and i'm going to go first
on this one if you have an opinion who
who's going Tanner tanner rocks yeah I
think um I don't know you know what I I
met the kid I've done a few actually we
did a YouTube collaboration together
once again haven't personally been
through his course but he did do a
number of trainings on my channel which
you know we as I said we did a collab
together he's young
I think he I think he's a smart kid I
believe he works hard I'm not sure he's
young smart when he taught the stuff he
taught on my channel regarding product
selection on on amaz
and all that stuff super legit you know
it was just you know he knows his
numbers he knows what he's doing
he sold products on Amazon before he's
obviously done the work he's not just a
pitchman okay
now stuff regarding his courses I don't
know if he teaches his own courses um so
I don't have anything to say there I do
know he like quit YouTube but then he
came back on and then he said he's not
selling courses and then he's selling a
different course so I think he's a
because he's so young he's a little bit
unfocused and I'm assuming just you know
but so I don't have I don't have much
more I don't have much more to say I
just I just don't have enough
information but he's a nice guy
again super bro like marketing John's
mark is like would I party with this
dude yes good guy yeah yeah I would
party I would party with I would party
with tanner
yeah pretty sure I wish I knew more
about tanner Fox is that our rating
system now it's like scam what like
would party with wouldn't heart wouldn't
party with figure not faking root weird
not weird
Tanner Fox I wish I knew more about him
all I know is he's just like the he just
reminds me of like a generic marketer
like just the other guy saying he'll
make you rich I mean after you go
through so many you just you feel like
you're seeing the same person again and
again and again
and it's obvious the people who are I
mean innovating in this space and the
people who aren't and I feel like he's
not done much innovation in my opinion
maybe an opportunist yeah that's it so
even though I criticize like all fake
gurus they're clearly fake gurus who are
like pushing the boundaries they're like
learning new things whatever and there's
some that are just like riding the wave
of well this makes money like this copy
makes money so I'm just gonna put it up
so that's what I would say fair enough
all right second to last one here that I
get we can add more if you guys would
like to because there's a bunch of who
come into comments but it's like we lost
one and Steven I'll let you start with
this one Grant Cardone do you have an
opinion on Greg Hart
so I used to be way more of a fan of
Grant Cardone than I am now I because
when I was doing house sales I knew a
fellow salesman who had really enjoyed
grants course and showed me and give it
gave me access to Grant's course so I've
actually taken some of grants course
I'll say about the course it was very
like old is very outdated like all the
modules were probably 10 years old
almost but I mean it was just basic
sales and so I thought to myself ok what
I liked about grant basically what I've
said from the beginning is at least he's
made money doing other things which I
always appreciate I like when people
have done what they propose to teach
before they teach this thing right so
he's actually I would say that grants a
very good salesman I don't think many
people would argue that what's come to
my attention though recently is that as
he pushes away from selling to
businesses and he starts selling more to
the individual I'm having more of a
problem with him as he's doing all these
conferences which are just giant upsells
like if guys I'm not trying to push you
away from my channel but Mike Wynn it
does some great videos about how Grant
Cardone pushes people into a bunch of
upsells through these like seminars that
are just giant upsells so they'll like
you'll go there and you'll end up
spending $20,000 on courses so I don't
like that about it I think he's become
much more of a fake guru he's seen the
huge wave he's seen the opportunity and
he's dived into that that combined with
the fact that he sued meet Kevin makes
me strongly dislike this guy not cool
now it's not cool to sue people like why
it's like free speech internet that's
like a cornerstone of my beliefs is like
dude let people say what they want to
say think grant cart you know I I think
grant cardone
overall I don't think anybody I don't
think there's even an argument of
whether the guy is a scam because he's
legit as hell but you know I think he's
a badass you know the guy the guy is the
guy's a badass the guy speaks his mind
the guy's not afraid to like smoke
cigars on camera or you know call you a
[ __ ] or all that stuff so I think he's
really he's he's I really like him I
like his energy I like all that stuff
that being said if if we are like if we
want to get some drama here I think
Jordan Belfort the [ __ ] original
sales person if you're looking to learn
sales you know what the wolf of Wall
Street is now moving into info products
and stuff and you know what this this
guy is the original set but he does it
and he Grant Cardone was selling
business to business you look at his
thing he was selling videotapes he was
selling his own sales training to car
dealerships back in the 80s okay
and so Grant Cardone didn't do as much
like on the ground boiler-room
business-to-consumer grind right that
Jordan Belfort did Grant Cardone I don't
know how long he did sales for but
basically he pivoted quickly into the
info product space and made a lot of his
money there so is he a badass does he
know sales yeah could you know is there
any problem with buying his course will
you learn a lot yes you'll definitely
learn a lot I think it'll be great
but is he the best I'd say Jordan
Belfort because it's just I think Jordan
Belfort just wins and I I learned sale
some sales from Jordan Belfort and I've
been through both the guy you know he's
just master also did you see where it
Grant Cardone was like saying in their
debate that disinterest is a level of
interest did you see that he's like that
was like I was like what do you know
what I'm about dude you're crazy
it's you know what Jordan Belfort got it
yeah I you like he's yet Grant Cardone I
already said it I'm I'm not calling I'm
not saying he's not legit or anything
but I'm saying I don't think he's the
best
you know what he's the most famous for
sure I don't think he's the best you
know it I don't yeah just fair enough
cool guy next guru and this is the last
one we have on the list again let me
know if you guys want to continue this
but um this is the moment I think
everybody the that are watching this
right now and the thousands that will
watch the recording of this as well as
the two of you I think this and myself
to be fair I think this is the moment
that we've all been waiting for and I
don't even think I need to really tell
you who it is but I'm going to cut
that's my job okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and just start with Stephen it's his
show I'm gonna let him lead the way on
this one Stephen what are your opinions
on Sifu himself okay so I cannot show
this what I have in my hands right now
is a cease and desist letter from Dan
Locke delivered to my house
the dude okay I got to be careful here
cuz he's like he's like a bat he's
getting really close to suing me right
now what what can one say about the king
of high ticket sales what could you say
about a guy like that he's oh I don't
know Jon like if you want to jump in
here I'm trying to think of how to
summarize my experience with Dan lock
spot it's really he's the shadiest guru
I've ever come into contact with and
researching him researching him makes me
want to take a shower
honestly the number of people that have
contacted me about Dan lock X far
exceeds any other guru that has ever
I've ever exposed on my channel nobody
comes close the amount of people who
said Dan lock I've lost all my money
dan lock put me in debt Dan lock this
and this dan locks course didn't work
for me dan lock is suing me dan lock
students are being sued
well anyway dan lock is just notoriously
litigious he sues people who disagree
with them he uses his money instead of
his words and I don't think that's gonna
get him far I think ultimately you live
and die by your reputation and while
he's really good at
shutting down public discussion the
conversation is happening whether he
likes it or not
and if he continues to hide behind
lawyers he's gonna fall farther and
farther behind because ultimately the
public knows just like you said John if
you're not gonna come on and say
something everyone knows you have
something to hide if you can't come on
and address it what are you hiding so
Dan Locke he's the King right now he's
the king of the fake gurus in my mind
he's the boss in the Bentley
he's the high-ticket I take a Salesman
it's all I can say oh and now he is an
investing expert I don't know if you
guys knew that he's selling a investing
seminar like he was a salon expert then
he's supposedly a social media expert
then he's a sales expert then he's a
investing expert he's the everything
expert if you could make money selling
it Dan Locke would be happy to to sell
you that ice to the Eskimos enough John
okay my opinion none of that's fact you
know there's this there's there's
douchebags and there's people who were
just like dicks and I don't know I I met
I came across Dan Locke at a fhl at
funnel hacking live and I don't know the
dude always has like five or six guys
dressed in like blacks matching black
suits and they all have like they have
their own they have their own like for
uh what is it called uniform they've got
their like basically they've got like
this business suit uniform that but
they're not businesspeople beaten but
they're high ticket closers so that was
kind of like weird but I was like oh you
know like I don't know any dude who like
walks around who's like hey you guys you
guys learn from me all this to dress
dress the same way and followed me
around everywhere and you know not make
eye contact I mean I don't know that's
kind of weird like first off like would
not party with like doesn't like you
know I don't I don't want some dude
coming in and like just he has all these
dudes in black right I may
it's marketing you know maybe it's just
like he's at a conference so he's gotta
like show up and like you know have all
I don't know it just seemed like it
seems a little off haven't actually you
know yeah I almost got sued by him
I got a cease and desist letter against
me because one of my affiliates exclude
oh yeah so that was it and that was the
real way we almost met is you know it
and to be fair like the the more you
move up in business the more a lawsuit
is kind of like it's like saying hello
it's like hey let's talk like yeah but
but you know what at our level like it
just is not necessary it's kind of rude
he could have yeah he's one can he's one
degree away from me
like all he has to do is ask one person
and we be connected and he just say hey
look John some of your affiliates or I
I'm not gonna mimic an Asian voice but
um no I'm not okay so he all he'd have
to say is hey John some of your
affiliates are advertising on my terms
can you tell him to stop or else we'll
you know we're gonna we're gonna sue sue
them and you too
so like something like that and I'd be
like oh cool thanks for bringing it to
my attention you know so I thought that
was a little rude I thought it's a
little weird that he has all these dudes
following him around it seems sort of
cultish which I don't know I understand
everybody wants to be a part of a tribe
but when you start turning a tribe or a
community into a cult I think you're I
think you're going too far so that's my
opinion on it also I did a bit of
research I did bit of my own research on
him when I saw him starting to blow up
um you know I I can't find the sales
experience me neither
so so you know I again I don't know I
you know it's that's those those are my
thoughts I haven't been through his
course I haven't talked to any people
who were success who have successfully
gone through his course how many out of
ten would you give him
so I think as YouTube content is very
motivating and I think it's very good
and I think he puts a lot of free
content out there so he gets some points
for delivering so much value to people
that is undeniable putting up free
content on YouTube is an immediate plus
if you're trying to sell [ __ ] in my book
um two three you know I I just I
couldn't find the experience they're
like and I think it's just weird I think
some of the stuff is weird
so that's where I stand I won't give him
a one simply because he's put he's
helping people a lot with with YouTube
but yeah I just I don't know that's
where I stand
we're kind of like lighting here right
now like I like to but in here real
quick it's time for our regularly
scheduled disclaimer from Spencer van so
Dan if you're watching this I do not
condone or district I don't agree or
disagree with anything they just said
I'm simply the moderator III you know
what I'm I'm all for business and you
know what if you want to chat about
something hit me up your peers what I'll
say to Dan let me give a personal
message Dan straight from the channel
owner okay you want to come on the
channel you're welcome anytime Dan yeah
come be a man Dan and come on the
channel all right come get some balls
and come on my channel because the
dodging the little little wordplay with
this enemy a lawsuit like if you know
where I live why don't you come where I
live and just let's talk why are we
doing this in interim you know let's
this talk man-to-man let's do it let's
do it buddy so good open invitation you
your people text my people you have my
contact information clearly and we will
hash it out live on coffee Zilla let's
do it
did you just challenged and lock oh for
sure oh I everybody watching if anybody
here also follows Dan's channel I would
let him know email is
or knew that that would dude I would be
so tuned into that think about the
content wow dude that would be that
would be that'll be fun you don't have
to be live not know I'm a hundred I'm
just like this okay this lets out fire
dude
that would be fire let's go let's go
I've got the night I would be I would
definitely be a million view video oh
you live stream for sure now let me ask
you guys this real quick I have a couple
names I've written down just from
comments that I've seen it seems like
people want to hear you guys opinion
would you guys like to do that or would
you guys like to just jump to I know
we've been on here for a while you guys
like to jump to our next let's get some
pennies let's get some chat going let's
work a little chat worth like so one of
the names I've seen pop up a ton here is
a Dan Pena Stephen if I know you made a
video on Dan Pena in regards to his wild
grizzly bear defense what opinion do you
have on Dan Pena I mean the guy is like
he's smart he's made a lot of money from
what I can tell now there's a little bit
of [ __ ] can you tell what we're where
have you seen he's made a lot of money
okay so actually I was gonna bring that
up because I've tried to figure out
where he makes his money and like it's
all from this sale sell of this company
Western oil or something like that but I
can't find any public records on it so
it's there's a bit of a question mark
for me for there but supposedly he had
this big buyout of like millions of
dollars there was a weird thing going on
with his company at the time where he
either got Elstad from his company like
the board was not happy with them
there's some kind of weird drama there
and he's very sensitive about it when
people have asked him and challenging
before there's like this video of him
freaking out when a kid challenges him
on where he made his money he like
threatens to like beat the kid and it's
like they're just again just answer the
question what's up with the fragile
millionaires so I think Dan Pena is
someone who is consistently exaggerating
everything about his life including the
Bears he's supposedly killed and he
never killed him
with his bare hands give me a break
including his testosterone levels he's
like saying he has the testosterone
levels of an Olympic athlete at the age
of like 70 years old give me a break
and then he calls himself like the 1
trillion dollar man now or he used to
call himself the 50 billion dollar man
which is misleading even though he
qualifies that as I've given 50 billion
dollars in value what does that mean
like how do you quantify that you can't
such as this big subjective number it'd
be like if I started throwing myself on
like I'm the 50 trillion dollar man
because millions of people have watched
my content and I'm gonna take credit for
all of their income collectively it's
like it's just dumb so not a fan of damn
pity he gives a lot of free stuff out
there so I like that but overall like
you know enough John I'm still I'm
interested in where where coffee found
that he made his money because as far as
I can tell everything that I've ever
seen about him is self-reported from my
from from my Luce research if I can
recall it he did he basically created
his own penny stocks and did pumping
dumps
he basically did a pump and dump of some
penny stock and like that was the sale
of the company or those his company
listed on the OTC the over OTC which is
over-the-counter exchange what the wolf
of Wall Street was doing and went to
jail for I think he just did it one time
or something I mean he claims to be the
CEO of Great Western resources where did
he make his money whereas Merrill that
that that thing for like millions of
dollars or whatever that's what he says
okay that's what he says all I all that
is verifiable is that he owns some curb
somehow he has possession of some kind
of castle in Ireland or whatever any
dresses up in a suit that's all we
compare there's some interesting
similarities between him and the other
gurus right so Dan Locke's a student of
his this guy Matt Lloyd who recently got
sued and went to jail or sorry not got
sued and lost to the FTC for like 300
million dollars was a student of his
Jason capital is also a student of his
I think there are a number of other
people who are uh who Spencer do you
know any other people who are students
of this no I'm not off the top of my
head no but I know those guys specific
yes so those guys for sure students of
his so he's had some of these like you
know pretty hardcore like Jason Capital
Jason cavil another cool dude what's and
by the way Jason's on our list so we can
know that but basically I find it weird
I think he's into this whole like secret
[ __ ] I think he's an actor I think
Dan Pena's an actor I think the whole
thing's an act I think he wrote some
fake story it's like Who am I in the
future and he's like I'm a five hundred
billion dollar man so I gotta start
calling myself a five hundred billion
dollar man I think the whole thing is an
act and he created this character
because he wanted to be rich and he just
started saying I'm how am I gonna make
money I'm gonna charge people to go in
my rented castle or some [ __ ] I don't
know let's go John let's go
no III think the guy I I don't know I
think the guy's a joke and I think the
whole like tough guy thing is I think
that's totally an act like what the you
know he's trying to get like business
people that I don't know that lost their
daddy or need a father figure so if you
ever want a guest spot on coffee Zillah
talking about Dan Pina dude if you gave
that same speech I hiked into that guy
he's I think dude honestly come on
having a guest spot from John Chris
Donnie on a dead Pina would be maybe one
of the greatest internet videos that
ever hits the market man oh my gosh that
was that was great I think I think in
that leave you agree with you though
like it is targeting people who like
lost their dads cuz he's like yeah you
need to grow up
you guys are garbage it's like hey what
are you doing what are you doing that
doesn't work yeah well I I've had people
say like yo you're gonna go to like the
castle summit like I just you know like
I've had people ask me if I want to like
you know sign up to and I'm just like
let me look into this guy and the more I
did research the more I was like I can't
find anything concrete here yeah perfect
on
that's gone this list is I mean I kinda
already spilled it so it's Jason capital
and John you brought him up so why don't
you go ahead and lead the way if you
haven't been well Alex is Jason capital
was his a pickup artist named so yeah
yeah yeah so jason capital is it's a
good sounding name yeah I I think the
guy's cool the guy's super dope
he runs a cool business he's super legit
he made money before he was a selling
info products he made money I mean he
made money selling info products of like
basketball training stuff houses first
thing he's speaking a basketball he
lives in Orange County or he lives in
Newport Beach so I office in Newport
Beach yeah he's made money selling info
products he's made money as an affiliate
marketer he's made money selling a
pickup artist kind of like how to pick
up chicks good-looking dude he's good
with the ladies you know a lot of fun
dude was party with he would like to
thumbs up guy to party with for sure and
he's a really intelligent hard-working
guy I have a lot of respect for Jason
capital I think he's very underrated as
far as uh the goo the gurus gurus go I
despite my the coffee Zilla army begging
me to make a video on him have never
done any research into the guy I've done
like very cursory stuff not much to say
about the guy I don't know pass fair
enough and then the last one that I've
seen pop up a lot and then we could go
on for this for hours right there's tons
of guys we could talk about but the last
big one I've seen come up a lot is a
Graham Stephen so I know you did a video
about him fairly recently right Steve
yeah yeah I did yeah I'm talking about
that I hate his definition of fake gurus
because he made it sound like the
industry is just a couple fly-by-night
sale like guys who are eventually gonna
leave the industry and the legit people
will rise to the top and I argued that
it's the opposite it's mostly scumbags
and there's like a few legit people mix
somewhere in that mix as far as Graham
Stefan as a person is it Steven or I
don't know what
I don't know goes by two first names -
I'm pretty sure he's another one of
those like - first name guys yeah I
think I think it's I'll just say Graham
Stephen sorry if you're watching I said
I could get my people to find his last
name if anybody yeah he's highly
intelligent seems like a honest dude for
the most part I like his a lot of his
stuff he's one of the few people that I
like I'll follow I'll watch his videos
for fun he puts on a lot of entertaining
free content that doesn't have like a
pitch at the end which I always like I'm
always appreciative of when people do
that so generally I like what he has to
say on that specifically I disagree and
I think he has a vested interest in it
because he's friends with a lot of these
guys so of course he's gonna say like oh
yeah it's totally legit that I'm
promoting Kevin David's course so it's a
way that he can get plausible
deniability because he himself is not
something of course like that but he's
creating income because a lot of the
courses that he sells from his his
YouTube promotions are affiliates and so
he's making tons of affiliate money
selling what I would argue are fake
gurus but then he's hiding under the
name of like oh I'm a legit guru because
I think he is but there's there's a
weird ethic there of like giving people
a platform and then profiting them from
them coming on your platform yourself I
think there's something shady going on
there i but that's all I have to say I
like him
generally though I think we could get
along I think he's a nice guy enough
John um I you know I I love advertising
on his channel the the advertising money
I spend on his channel is very
profitable big big fan great things yeah
yeah well yes the channel the the
advertising we do on his channel is
profitable so we we do like that I
haven't ever met the guy haven't ever
talked to the guy even I think he's uh
yeah I know he's coming out with a quote
I think he's coming out with courses or
he started coming out with courses I
don't know if he teaches them himself I
don't know how best he is in teaching
but I know he's all from what I see of
him on YouTube because I watch his
videos sometimes very smart
I highly intelligent very hard worker to
put up a video a day like I batch my
batard world oh yeah I batch my videos
like I'll do like 20 I'll do like 15
videos in a day and I'll just shoot for
a couple days and then I'll you know
schedule them out for the next few
months like because I couldn't do a
video every single day to like get
prepared and get the mice he does so
much content I mean and he really puts
thought into it and he's really like
takes a lot of work and I have respect
for a man who is upfront who puts in a
lot of work you know he really just blew
up the last two years it's yeah
oh and he's gigantic he's got a gigantic
channel now two channels so I I respect
people have hard work that being said
some of the things he teaches people you
know he's like spend 20 cents on coffee
like I don't know you don't have to be
that freakin cheap man like that guy is
I think the guy takes cheap to a whole
new level like that guy is just like you
know he's making what he said he made
like a million dollars last year like
you don't need to buy 20 cent coffee I
think that's some part of his act that
he just kind of sticks with now um you
could spend a little money you know it's
I don't know you don't have to be that
cheap like he's just so cheap it's it's
kind of annoying I don't know like like
I don't know like I'd like a legit but
like probably wouldn't party with I
think that's a great way to conclude the
fake guru segment I guess it's not
really the segment this whole things
about figures but the Guru weight rating
segments John it's official would not
party with Graham but there's a select
few that John will party with and I
think we've discovered that today and
that brings us to our last category and
this is something you guys wanted to
open up more of a discussion to let you
guys go to and that is webinar and
really I guess just sales tactics in
general for these these programs and
yeah I think it would be great if maybe
Stephen if you could start off with kind
of the main couple points that you have
against it and kind of the main things
you don't like and then John can
rebuttal and we could go from there yeah
so I don't want to disagree with what
you asked me but I'm gonna try to answer
it a bit differently
because what I was hoping for in this
section and because this is the last
section
I thought we'd open it up we've had a
lot of back-and-forth of like
disagreeing with each other so I wanted
to turn this more into a talk about so
not like I disagree no you disagree now
this this is I wanted to forge on to
kind of put us in the mindset of how to
sell to people like through webinars and
like what he's thinking about when he's
crafting because it's rare that I get
like an insider a true insider in I mean
Spencer you're an insider but John you
kind of have like yura you're a really
aggressive market I'd like you to run us
through what you're thinking about when
you do that in the way of like mechanics
how does it mechanically work when you
put in this line you know okay this is
gonna work really well how do you know
it's a good line right that's what I
want to go for so I hope you could maybe
walk us through some of that okay
yeah just interject and ask questions
we're but basically I mean yeah what I'm
questions from chat as well like
interspersed in here you know
so what I'm thinking when when somebody
clicks on an ad I want I want to come as
close to the effect of a UFO spaceship
landing outside your black bedroom
window where you're just like what the
heck this can't be real I need to go
over and check this thing out like it
doesn't matter if you were having sex
with your girlfriend it doesn't matter
if you're on the phone with your mom if
a UFO landed in your backyard if you're
looking out your window and little green
men started coming out of that you would
put the phone down and you would
immediately go over to see what's going
on right away
so in marketing we call that a pattern
interrupt or a hook you know or
clickbait you know you could call it
million different things but when I
start my webinars I'm trying to get that
freaking up back and that's why I use
Lamborghinis that's why I have
helicopters that's why I have like just
monstrously obscenely large mansions
that I use because I want to have that
effect where people are like holy [ __ ]
like this is insane like I want to give
people an idea of the amount of money
that is out there for them to claim
because screenshots are I mean
screenshots are lame and a lot of the
other so I try to go I try to take what
other marketers do and I try to go the
next level other marketers are using
screenshots they're like hey check out
these nice screenshots that people send
me I try to go next level and and also
make it exciting because my visual you
look at all the people you're the intro
to your new webinar cuz I was gonna I
was gonna roast it but it's an
interesting case study unlike me what
actually you're doing here so this is no
I know I've got it I've got it I'm gonna
show it oh it's it's you uh so that's
John Chris Donnie's helicopter coming up
literally he's taking the spaceship
thing literally here here we go
let's see here you'll see a pop-up in a
second shot take a shower and get a job
is that what somebody's telling me
webinar starting well everybody can hear
me hey John Chris Donnie here sorry I'm
a little bit late wait hold on hold on
hold on is this for your live webinar is
this for your live webinar like your
live pre-recorded live webinar cuz
you're like is always this thing live
now okay so you want to go to the live
verse thing you know what what's funny
this is another funny thing about human
psychology people are more apt to watch
something
they think it's live versus been it was
reported who cares though just tell them
it's J it's pre-recorded live I don't
tell them it's not live I don't tell I
don't tell I well sorry I never tell
them it's live either no no let's go
back to your cuz you say is this think
you I hold on let's go back to exactly
what you it was live at one point so
that's that's where you get into this
little like marketing realm but we test
it people love people love it and you
got to make but overall it may if you
don't if you tell them this is recorded
it loses the appeal okay and I want to
add education to be exciting so one of
the people I follow very closely is Elon
Musk whenever he says something about
education I follow it very closely and
what Elon Musk said it was somebody
asked him because he has his own school
yeah he built a school for his kids and
they said what should education be what
is you know how do you innovate
education
he says education should be like a
Batman action movie it should be like
Batman with lots of cuts and excitement
and special effects and what I look at
this is I'm creating something that's
exciting that makes people excited too I
interrupt their day and give them an
exciting basically a action movie with
you know hot girls and helicopters and
also training so I make it fun the thing
is okay actually I wanna I wanted to hit
a discussion here because we just
happened to into this so I hate to make
it into another debate but there's
actually something that I've found
happens when you turn education into
entertainment it ceases to be
educational and it people all they
remember is the entertainment no it's
true it's true that's education should
be boring that's no it's not it's not
the Lori's but the point is I mean throw
a mic and five girls at the front of the
class or if you throw a bunch of hot
girls at the front of a calculus class
they're not gonna remember the calculus
John do you agree with me if you put a
hot girl at the front of the calculus
class but if you if you put a hot girl
in the front of the calculus class you
say hey look if you pay attention and
differentiate
if you pay attention to this if you pay
attention to this class you can get you
can marry somebody that looks like this
and then you kick her out yeah III don't
I'm not sitting there teaching in front
of a helicopter I arrived in the
helicopter then I go into education I
hold on let me play the end of this let
me play the end of this clip let me play
the end of this clip one second by the
way let me say I agree with the hook
thing I just disagree that education
itself should be exciting to be clear
okay well everybody can hear me the
webinar starting there it is and then
it's nice check this out how many times
did you have to do this to get the girl
to walk out at the right amount of time
and the cash on the table again what's
up Brian so that one was actually what
was actually Haram out okay so she was a
cool were set up here bro so we the
first time you know we did like five
takes of this whole intro sequence over
a period of time because we'd have to
like you know we'd have to loop the
helicopter around and we had to call
flight control it was a it was a big
shoot there was a lot of fun it was kind
of like a like a movie set but to get
the girl to do that well the first time
we had we said hey we we meet you know
we brought the girl in I think she was
drinking like hey someone to do that to
do like a scene where they're in a
bikini and they walk out and they do the
shot I think we paid him a hundred bucks
each but we told him there was like you
know my buddy he's like in a famous band
and he said he was like he's like come
hang out I'm in Palm Springs on a
YouTube shoot like there's free alcohol
hang out by the pool you'll have to work
for like 30 minutes but that's about it
they're like oh cool like they just want
to hang out so you don't have to pay
much all right
yeah drinking the whole time they were
having fun it was pretty it's kind of
distracting see you can't it can't be
educated when you're distracted John
that's my whole point
all right no so then you get the hook
you get the hook then what it's like
then it's like how do you get them from
cold they're cold traffic they don't
know you from Adam too like I'm gonna
buy a $997 course um well you have to
let people know what you're what you're
offering them you know you're either
offering them you know better health
better wealth better relationships
better cooking skills whatever you're
offering them just to kind of lead them
through and you gotta really it's all
about just figuring out what are
people's objections to bind what are the
reasons why people wouldn't buy and then
essentially just addressing every reason
that people might not buy maybe they
don't believe me right maybe they don't
believe that I actually make a lot of
money or made a lot of money or whatever
maybe they don't trust that my company
will deliver a good like training and
support system maybe they don't trust
that my product actually works maybe
they believe that I'm a great guy and
I've made a lot of money but they don't
believe my training will actually be
effective so I have to address those
concerns then a house have to dress the
other concerns which is you know this
you know this costs a lot of money is
this is this actually worth the price or
is $1,000 a bad price for this I have to
address other things such as does this
take technical skills right like a lot
of people those skills require very
technical other objections are you know
is this something I can you know is this
a short term you know is it saturated
yeah that's a big one is this saturated
have too many people done affiliate
marketing or is there still you know
like room to make money so you have
basically I'm just knocking out all the
objections and if I can convince people
that no this is a good value yes you
have the skills to do this now yes there
is opportunity doing this I'm a good
person
my company is a good trustworthy company
and the
works if I can convince people of all of
those things that's just what I'm doing
for two for two hours I'm literally just
addressing those concerns in a variety
of different ways now that's I find it
I've always found it interesting that
like people on YouTube to get retention
they're all about short short short
short short and all the webinars are
hour plus sorry that's my dog barking
but all the webinars are an hour plus y
in like Y over an hour is it just you
need time with people to make them feel
like they know you what is it there's a
direct correlation with how much time
you spend with somebody with how much
money you'll spend with them and how
much you feel like you trust them
usually so the longer you spend with
somebody you're not gonna marry somebody
on let's say you you know I don't know
you have a wife or something you don't
you may have it may have been love at
first glance but you're not gonna marry
at first glance you're gonna you're you
you have to spend time with somebody
until you actually close that deal so if
you notice most deals most you know even
when you're buying a car most buying
decisions are made in about an hour you
know if you go to the car dealership
you're gonna spend about it maybe about
an hour all in talking to people talking
you know going for a test-drive
etc before you make a purchase decision
some people are longer some people will
make purchase decisions shorter but if
I'm you know I'm trying to convince
people to make a big life change I'm
trying to get them to spend the next six
weeks with me to spend a thousand
dollars with me so that's it's a big
commitment so I need to you know I have
to spend a lot of time with people in
order to convince them to literally give
up 30 minutes a day or an hour a day for
the next six weeks of their life and
give me a thousand dollars to you know
it takes time yeah you know you it's not
something you're just kind of like hey
you know piers appears of course on
udemy attend all you have to sell it
right right right
okay all right I'm gonna call an audible
here because I see that chat wants a
little bit more fire they want a little
bit more
so let no no no IIIi don't mean you were
providing great value but they want us
to disagree a bit so let me say this let
me say this let me say this
John think of a question that you wanted
to ask me maybe it's a little
contentious maybe it's a little bit like
outside the ballpark you're gonna ask me
that and I want to ask you is there such
a thing as taking advertising too far
and selling too high price of a product
and misleading people and if there is
what is that point for you what at what
point would you say I cannot ethically
support this and do you know of a guru
who's doing that can you like use an
example of this guru I don't I don't
agree with what they're doing I
definitely think there's at least one
person you named which is doing it to
another ethical degree not gonna name a
name but I do I do I do think there is
one person out there people chat can
probably chatters can probably figure
out but I think he's he's gone a bit
over the line and what is that line for
you like which part is the line where is
like you can't say this if you know your
brain I mean if you if you know that you
are really just I don't know if you if
there's a track record of just people
that are disgusted with your product and
they are saying they feel brainwashed
and you know just it's I I think that's
a bit over the line where people where
people are literally cut you know they
exit the program and they come out and
they say I wasn't even thinking right
for that period of my life because I was
so brainwashed that's bad that's bad
yeah I I know exactly who you're talking
about now yeah yeah yeah I think people
can say it rip I mean people in chat who
are saying like figure it out
guys just he used the key word that I've
used myself to describe this person so
you guys can figure it out chat use the
the wisdom of the crowd here to find out
who John
talking about wisdom of the crowd how
people are figuring it out yeah most
people are figuring it out okay so do
you have a question for me that what was
the question that I had was there was
there a particular question that I I
brought up in the pre call then I was
gonna ask you I don't know I I think the
big thing I think the big thing was uh I
guess have you know I'm trying to think
what was my question
hmm no man I mean I also you know one
thing I want to say to you though is I
do want to commend you for like bringing
out like for bringing on for being able
to bring on the other side on your
channel I think what you're doing is
great it I think it makes sense I think
calling out like the fake gurus there is
no regulation here and there are there
is a lot of opportunity for people to be
scammed I believe this is the future of
Education I'm long on education overall
and I think what you're doing is adding
a lot of value to the entire ecosystem I
think people should be calling each
other out I think but at the same note I
really you know I commend you and I
think you have a lot of you know balls
or guts or whatever you want to say you
know are a lot of a truth or honesty to
yourself for allowing the other side to
actually come on and say what say you
know say our side from the guru-guru
side of things about what our thoughts
are and why we're doing things I believe
this is a legitimate industry I think
it's great but there are a lot of bad
actors because there aren't enough
people like you calling them out so I
think it's actually all healthy and I'm
looking you know I I'd love to see
I'd love to see you call out more people
in the future I started going on some of
the medical things but dude I think just
could call people out man like they
there
are more people here and the histories
are interesting on a lot of these
people's so I don't know I think it's
fine I I think call them out and and
invite them on and say hey if you want
to hear your side come the heck on and
we'll hear your side
I think that's healthy fair enough
Spencer do you have any final questions
I'm thinking look let's keep it let's
keep it short and tight we've already
been going on here for probably what two
hours now some we're approaching that
yeah two hours so any final questions
from the chat or anybody want to wrap
anything up and we'll get out I think
thank you for that by the way John and
thank you again for coming on man like
I've said it several times but I feel
like maybe you're a domino of people
were waiting for a guru who got called
out to come on and have the courage to
come on and say their side maybe people
didn't believe me when I said I would be
happy to do it but uh I'm really happy
you didn't hopefully in the future
people believe me when I say you can
come on you really can't I'm an email
away let's talk awesome guys well yeah I
think I mean that's it for me I don't
have anything else and again I think
this has been great and you know what
real quick I want to actually ask the
chat can you guys in the check you guys
give John a - you guys are thankful that
John was able to come on here can we get
some twos for John and then we also get
some twos for for coffee Zillah if you
guys Globus content cuz I think I think
we need to show some appreciation John's
house thanks John thanks John for facing
the music at first I was looking at the
chat and then I was just like oh this is
ugly
no people ultimate they always respect
people who come on say their piece I
mean we don't the point of this also
guys for everyone who like wants me to
care John's head off the point of this
is not to tear John's head off therefore
the point is to like address like some
of the concerns if you guys wanted like
a deathmatch we can do that but me and
John came together we asked what did we
want to get out of this we could have
you know there may be a deathmatch if
the people want a deathmatch will
eventually give them a deathmatch will
give the people whatever they want
dan Locke if Dan lock comes on it has to
be a death
cuz I have so much to say to Dan if he
comes on it has to be I don't mean
literally above course I mean like it
has to be a real knock-down drag-out but
yeah thanks guys thanks for bunch of
two's in chat all right guys
love ya thanks chopper coming on thanks
Spencer for moderating you were terrific
and yeah that's it that's all for now
see you